what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime outbroad and today i will be
talking about the very latest
developments
in the boku no hero story including the
fact that the villains have now
seemingly completely turned the tables
on the heroes
just a few chapters ago it seemed as if
everything was going according to plan
for the heroes
and the villains looked to be on the
ropes but
in my previous videos i warned that this
is definitely a psych out by horikoshi
and these last two chapters have
definitely proven it
major hero losses are coming these last
few chapters have
changed everything so let's get
into it if you enjoyed the bokudo hero
content on this channel and you want us
to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications if you want to get
notified you really have to go through
the trouble of clicking the bell and
then selecting the option that says all
if you don't you still probably won't
see our videos even if you're subscribed
it's just how youtube works
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers
we're talking about the latest events in
the story so please proceed with caution
you have been warned so right as
shigaraki is
finally awakening back in jakku hospital
the story switches focus yet again
and we find out what happened just
moments earlier back at the villain
mansion
you will recall that during the hawks vs
dobby fight fat gum had been running
away from the mansion
and using the fat taxi to carry tokoyami
kaminari juzo and mushroom girl back to
safety
after they did what they had to do on
the front lines
but as fat gum passed by the place where
hawks and dabi were fighting
tokuyami saw what was going on and he
decided that he couldn't just leave
hawks to die
he considers hawks to be his mentor and
so tokoyami uses dark shadow to forcibly
escape
fat taxi the young hero student then
flies
into the thick of the battle in order to
save hawks from certain death at the
hands of dabi
fat gum is shocked that tokyomi was able
to escape his fat since apparently no
one has ever been able to do that before
and fat gum yells at tokuyami not to go
because it's too dangerous
but tokuyami has already flown away and
so fat gum has no choice but to let the
other students go
he tells them to run the rest of the way
on their own while he rushes after
tokoyami in order to protect him from
getting deep fried by the villains
tokuyami manages to fly into the
building and he puts himself
in dark shadow between hawks and dobby
dark shadow is instantly shocked by the
extent of hawks's burns and
other injuries and meanwhile dobby is
completely disgusted by how low
the heroes have sunk they were so
desperate that they brought a bunch of
high school students to fight for them
which is bad enough but also the heroes
themselves are completely corrupt and
hypocritical
at least according to dobby throughout
this chapter dobby is doing a lot of
hero bashing
and there is a reason why he's talking
so much but we'll get to that in a
little bit
first off i really want to talk about
the fact that tokuyami just defied
orders from his superiors
during an active mission in order to
help hawks
i also want to again emphasize that
knowing full well that dobby's quirk
is the generation of deadly flames
tokoyami still had the cojones to step
in between darby and hawks in order to
protect hawks from future attacks
as much as this can be seen as a
reckless and foolish move for a hero
student to make
especially since he was specifically
ordered not to do anything like this
you really have to respect tokoyami he
has just shown extreme courage
and he has shown incredible loyalty to
his mentor hawks
he deserves mad respect for that but at
the same time
he is also putting his own life and the
overall plan
at risk this could definitely backfire
massively but we'll have to wait and see
second
i am really worried about hawks right
about now
judging by dark shadow's reaction
hawks's injuries
are terrifying and his life is in
serious danger i mean hawks could
literally die within the next
chapter or two and even if he survives
these injuries may prevent him from
being a pro hero for the rest of his
life
things definitely look really bad for
hawks and i think we should all be
concerned about him
granted my primary concern and my
absolute priority is best girl miroko
as you guys all know if you've seen my
recent mha videos
but this hawk situation is definitely
scary as well
at this point it really could go either
way hawks might survive
or he might succumb to his injuries
dobby then tries to make tokoyami
question his loyalty to hawks by telling
him what hawks
just did hawks just killed someone by
stabbing them
in the back someone who considered hawks
to be his friend
as that person was trying to go out and
protect his friends
dobby is of course talking about twice
and he is trying to say that even though
twice
wasn't a direct threat to hawks in that
moment and even though he was actually
running away from hawks
hawks still decided to kill him for what
he considered to be
the greater good dobby is trying to get
tokuyami to question the nature of the
pro heroes
and he tells tokyomi that the pro hero
ideal that he is dreaming of becoming
is far dirtier than he thinks the heroes
are more corrupt
than the villains they just refuse to
recognize it
at least according to dobby clearly
dobby really hates the hero society
and the role of pro hero in particular
in some ways this is similar to stain
and we know that dobby was inspired by
stain
but in other ways dobby's views are
different from stains
stain did believe in the hero ideal
he just felt that many heroes are
corrupting that ideal in the
pursuit of personal gain but stain did
believe that real heroes
still exist including notably all might
and deku and yet dabi seems to loathe
the very concept of pro hero he doesn't
seem to think that there are any
good pro heroes out there he believes
that all pro heroes are dirty and
corrupt hypocrites because the very
notion of a pro hero is a lie it is just
an illusion that society has created
but the truth about pro heroes is far
darker and dirtier than anyone wants to
admit
but tokuhami explains that he's just
concerned about his mentor and teacher
making it clear that he isn't here to
argue about philosophy or the nature of
the hero society as a whole
dabi is disappointed by this and he
launches yet
another fire blast tokyomi quickly grabs
hawks and he tries to get out of the way
of the attack
but the room is too cramped so he can't
avoid the attack completely
and on top of that dobby's flame is
making
dark shadow weaker because as we know
tokyomi's quirk is stronger when it is
dark and it is weaker when there is a
lot of light
tokuyami quickly realizes that he needs
to get out of this room
as soon as possible he needs to escape
dobby's flames and get hawks to a doctor
immediately if they stay here any longer
dobby is going to make
chicken nuggets out of both of them
however hawks
as injured as he is notices something
important
dabi is talking a lot instead of just
finishing hawks and tokyomi off with
overwhelming force dobby keeps talking
about the heroes being corrupt and the
problems of the hero society
it is as if dabi is stalling because he
can't just keep attacking
over and over again it is as if he is
talking in order to
buy time for himself because overusing
his quirk
hurts dobby's own body so he has to pace
himself
as tokuyami is figuring all this out
with the hub of hawks hawks tells him to
go
now and tokumi takes off with hawks in
his arms
they use dark shadow's powers to quickly
escape to the lower floors
of the building dark shadow is actually
quite weak in this moment because of all
the light that had been coming from
dobby's flames
but it does manage to get tokyomi and
hawks to the lower floors
but just barely once they're safe on the
ground tokumi realizes that hawks is
unresponsive
but thankfully he is still breathing
since down here on the lower floors
there is no fire
tokumi prepares to use black fallen
angel to fly away
with hawks but in that moment
dobby suddenly shows up in front of them
and it appears that he is
actually flying just like endeavour
dobby seems to be able to concentrate
flames around his feet
and then use this ability to temporarily
propel himself
through the air i mean what a shocker
that dobby's
quirk has so many similarities to
endeavors but let's move on
dobby then prepares to launch another
fire blast at the two heroes
but he is suddenly interrupted by what
looks like a massive avalanche
getting has finally entered the chat and
he is able to use his overpowered ice
manipulation abilities
to force the massive mount lady to fall
back and crash
into a bunch of trees now that is
power being able to send even someone
like mount lady
in her giant form absolutely flying into
the distance
other heroes appear to be caught up in
giton's attack as well
and essentially getting's attack has
almost single-handedly disrupted the
hero siege
it looks like getting might have just
changed the entire momentum
on the battlefield thankfully tokoyami
is able to use getting's attack as a
distraction and he manages to escape
from dabi with hawks in his arms
with tears in his eyes tokoyami cries
out to hawks that he is not corrupt and
that everyone believes that he is doing
the right thing
tokuyami then begs hawks not to die and
i think that we all feel the same
after all if hawks does regain
consciousness
he will immediately be able to reveal
the secret of dobby's identity
the secret which dobby revealed to him
but which was hidden from us
the readers dobby revealed his secret
because he thought he was gonna kill
hawks anyway so hawks could never get a
chance to reveal it to anyone else
but now that hawks escaped with
tokoyami's help
he could reveal the truth to everyone as
long as he actually survives and regains
consciousness the action then shifts to
the underground complex where redestro
and the other villains are still located
re destroy is trying to find his spare
leg when someone calls out to him
redestro is suddenly informed that
gigantomachia
just stood up he is
finally moving and gigantomachia even
says that he can smell his
master's scent and that is how this
action-packed chapter ends with the
tables quickly turning on the heroes at
the mansion and with the momentum
shifting in favor of the newly awakened
shigaraki
and the villains tokuyami and hawks seem
to have gotten away
but getting's attack looks like it threw
a major wrench
into the hero's plans and of course the
fact that gigantomachia is now on the
move is extremely bad news for the
heroes
qiganto machia can level an entire city
he is an
absolute monster so his awakening is no
joke
the heroes believed that gigantomachia
wouldn't do anything because he only
takes orders from all for one
and all for one is in prison but on the
final page of this chapter
gigantomachia says that he can smell his
master
scent now you might think that when he
says master gigantomachia is actually
referring to all for one
but he could also be talking about the
successor of all for one
shigaraki it is quite possible that he
is actually referring to shigaraki
since shigaraki has just awakened around
that exact time
and of course all for one's quirk the
real
all for one and not the copy has also
just awakened
inside shigaraki i wonder if that is why
the master
scent is now coming off of shigaraki
himself
shigaraki's body has changed drastically
in order to accommodate the quirk
all for one and so perhaps gigantomachia
now
senses and smells this change
in regards to dobby i think it's
important to mention that
some panels in this chapter were clearly
emphasizing the fact that dobby's quirk
definitely damages his body when he
overuses it
this is a major limitation of his
otherwise overpowered quirk
and when you think about it this might
be the reason why his father endeavor
didn't consider him to be a good enough
of a candidate for surpassing all might
and so endeavour gave all his attention
to shoto instead
everything is finally falling into place
and coming together to explain the truth
about
dobby and at this point i am absolutely
assuming that he
is toya todoroki i believe that he had a
powerful quirk
and endeavor wanted to push him to be
stronger than all for one
but because of his drawback that harmed
his body he just
couldn't do it and i think for this
reason
endeavor rejected him traumatized him
and turned him
into this villain known as dobby i would
be absolutely
shocked if the truth ended up being
anything other
than that man i can't believe that just
a few chapters ago
things were looking so good for the
heroes in both locations
jakku hospital and the villain mansion
they had the element of surprise
they had made the first move and they
were seemingly accomplishing all of
their goals
the villains were losing and the heroes
were winning but
now with shigaraki's awakening getting's
epic gamer move and the rising of
gigantomachia
things look very different the heroes no
longer have the element of surprise
and they no longer have the momentum
things are about to get
very ugly for the heroes in both
locations and i have a feeling that all
the hero students will end up
becoming a lot more involved in the
fight on the front lines than they
ever thought they would be man this is
getting so crazy
and so freaking good again i'm loving
this chapter and other than the fact
that i really want miracle to survive
and if she doesn't i will riot
i'm extremely excited about how this arc
is moving forward
and i can't wait to see what happens
next important characters including
heroes
are definitely going to suffer and some
will die
there is just no way around it with
everything that we've seen so far
and no matter what happens the hero
society will never be the same again
the truth about dabi will be revealed
gigantomachia shigaraki getten
and the others will cause major damage
to the heroes and a number of top tier
heroes like hawks and miroko
have already been severely injured these
are society changing events that are
currently taking place
in the boku no hero story and things
will never be the same again
please let me know what you guys think
will hawks regain consciousness and
reveal the truth
about dobby are the heroes about to get
absolutely slapped by
shigaraki and gigantomachia who will
survive
and who will die please share your
thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want us to
keep it going
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime outpour or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram
at animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for supporting our work
and making these videos
possible special thank you to a friend
a a disciple of lord twego
himself another important thank you to
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata
alolan adam the world steelers tyson
quirino a quiet respect
pate heffa jonathan king desi d brandon
aviles
and emperor otaku finally i can't forget
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
jason wilson king zeldris anatoly
kazotsky on hell cruz
isparky65 cricket xp 10 no ted
joe stanton very gucci alicia octor
animal is 69 jessica kayla fond
hinokamien water
bonnie parks zodiart12 rathuen
deora emperor mitch loves anime and jcc
waka
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you please
consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]